.
IT'S LIKE BAITING DEER.
WE'RE OPPOSED.
>> Sean: YOU'LL WIN HONESTLY.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
THE TRUST FUND BRAT THAT NEVER
WORKED A DAY IN HIS LIFE, JOHN
FETTERMAN, WAS FORCED TO ANSWER
WHY HE COULDN'T COME ON THIS
PROGRAM AND DEFEND HIS RADICAL
POSITIONS.
HERE'S A TEASE.
>> SEAN HANNITY WANTED YOU TO BE
A GUEST ON HIS NATIONAL TV SHOW.
HE SAYS HE HAS NO RESPONSE FROM
YOU WHICH I ASSUME MEANS A NO.
SO MY QUESTION, AS A UNITED
STATES SENATOR AND I WORK FOR
ONE THAT WOULD BE THE LATE JOHN
HINES, YOU HAVE TO DEBATE THE
OPPOSITION THING ALL THE TIME.
I'M CURIOUS AS TO WHAT YOUR
REASONING IS FOR NOT DOING THAT?
>> Sean: WE GOT AN ANSWER.
WE'LL PLAY HIS FULL ANSWER
TONIGHT.
ALSO TONIGHT, WE HAVE JUST
OBTAINED EXCLUSIVELY FOR THIS
PROGRAM TWO FULL HOURS OF BODY
CAM FOOTAGE FROM THE 2020
INCIDENT INVOLVING SENATOR
RAPHAEL WARNOCK OF GEORGIA AND
HIS EX-WIFE WHERE SHE ACCUSED
HIM OF RUNNING HER OVER WITH HIS
TESLA FOLLOWING A DOMESTIC
DISPUTE.
THOSE THAT SAY BELIEVE ALL
WOMEN.
ARE THEY FAINTING OUTRAGE OVER
HERSCHEL WALKER BECAUSE HE
ALLEGEDLY PAID FOR AN ABORTION
YEARS AGO?
ARE THEY ONLY CARRYING ABOUT
WOMEN THAT ACCUSED REPUBLICANS?
IS THIS GOING TO CHANGE THE RACE
IN GEORGIA?
WE HAVE THAT TAPE COMING UP HERE
ON THIS SHOW.
ARIZONA DEMOCRAT KATIE HOBBS IS
RUNNING AND HIDING LITERALLY
FROM TOUGH QUESTIONS.
SHE STILL REFUSES TO DEBATE KARI
LAKE.
WE HAVE EXCLUSIVE VIDEO OF HER
FRANTICALLY AVOIDING A REPORTER.
WE BEGIN WITH JOE BIDEN WHO SAT
DOWN FOR ONE OF THE COZIEST --
COULD HAVE LIT A FIRE AND
TOASTED MARSHMALLOWS INTERVIEW
WITH CNN'S FAKE JAKE TEPPER WHO
CODDLED THE PRESIDENT WITH A
VARIETY OF SOFTBALL QUESTIONS
AND NO FOLLOW UPS.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, FAKE JAKE, HE'S
NOT A JOURNALIST.
HE'S A DEMOCRATIC ACTIVIST, A
TALK SHOW HOST.
I'M A TALK SHOW HOST.
WE'RE MEMBERS OF THE PRESS.
I'M HONEST, HE'S NOT.
IT'S OKAY.
JUST BE HONEST WITH HIS VIEWERS.
HE SAYS HE HAS A POLITICAL SIDE.
HE'S A TRUMP HATING DEMOCRAT
LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE ON FAKE NEWS
CNN AND MSDNC.
DESPITE TAPPER'S BEST EFFORT TO
BE GENTLE WITH THE PRESIDENT,
THE EVER SO, WELL, COMPROMISED
PRESIDENT POLITELY PICKING UP
JOE'S CHEAT SHEET.
BIDEN STILL MANGLED AT THE END
TO MAKE A TOTAL COMPLETE FOOL OF
HIMSELF.
MANGLING ONE WORD AFTER ANOTHER.
HE SAID HE WAS SO PROUD OF HIS
SON, HUNTER, THE SMARTEST GUY HE
KNOWS.
MAY BE TRUTH TO THAT.
HE MADE ALL OF THIS MONEY WITH
NO EXPERIENCE.
HAVE TO GIVE THE DEVIL HIS DUE.
HE SAID THE VAST MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS APPROVE HIS DECISIONS
IN OFFICE.
I BEG TO DIFFER.
HE SAID THAT WE'RE DEFINITELY
NOT IN A RECESSION.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SHOULD THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
PREPARE FOR A RECESSION?
>> NO.
THEY'VE BEEN SAYING THIS EVERY
SIX MONTHS.
THEY LOOK DOWN THE NEXT SIX
MONTHS AND SEE IF IT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN.
IT'S NOT HAPPENED YESTERDAY.
THERE IS NO GUARANTEE THAT THERE
IS -- I DON'T THINK THERE WILL
BE A RECESSION.
IF IT IS, IT WILL BE A SLIGHT
RECESSION.
WE'LL MOVE DOWN SLIGHTLY.
>> Sean: SEE, AFTER TWO STRAIGHT
QUARTERS OF NEGATIVE GROWTH,
CONSECUTIVE QUARTERS OF NEGATIVE
GROWTH, WE'RE OFFICIALLY IN A
RECESSION NOT TO MENTION A
HOUSING CRASH, A BEAR MARKET AND
SPIKING INTEREST RATES AND
INFLATION STILL AT A 41-YEAR
HIGH.
GAS PRICES ARE NOW MORE THAN
DOUBLE WHAT THEY WERE UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THEY'RE
GOING HIGHER VERY QUICKLY.
THAT BRINGS US TO BIDEN'S UTTER
HUMILIATION AT THE HANDS OF OPEC
AND SAUDI ARABIA.
REMEMBER AFTER HE WENT BEGGING
AND PLEADING WITH MBS, THE GUY
HE ONCE CALLED THE MURDERERS OF
JAMAL KHAISHOGGI AND BEGGED THEM
TO PLEASE PRODUCE MORE OIL, THE
COUNTRY THAT HE SAID WAS A
PARIAH NATION, THE KINGDOM OF
SAUDI ARABIA?
THEY IN CONJUNCTION WITH OPEC IN
ALIGNMENT WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN
AND RUSSIA, THEY DECIDED TO DO
THE EXACT OPPOSITE OF WHAT JOE
WANTED AND THEY PRODUCE LESS.
HE GOT ON A HIS HANDS AND KNEES,
KISSED THE RING OF MBS AND
DIDN'T WORK.
EVEN FIST PUMPED HIM.
TWO MILLION BARRELS A DAY LESS
THANKS TO JOE'S DIPLOMACY.
ACCORDING TO JOE BIDEN, IT WAS
NEVER ABOUT THE OIL.
THIS IS A LIE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU THINK IT'S TIME FOR THE
U.S. TO RETHINK ITS RELATIONSHIP
WITH SAUDI ARABIA?
>> YES.
BY THE WAY, LET'S GET STRAIGHT
WHY I WENT.
I DIDN'T GO ABOUT OIL.
I WENT ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT WE
MADE SURE WE WEREN'T GOING TO
WALK AWAY FROM THE MIDDLE EAST.
WHAT WAS GOING ON.
>> Sean: OKAY.
HE WENT THERE FOR THE OIL.
HE WENT THERE TO BEG SAUDI
ARABIA FOR HELP IN THE MID
TERMS.
WE NOW HAVE A BOMB SHELL REPORT
FROM THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL"
THAT JOE BIDEN WAS PLEADING WITH
OPEC AND SAUDI ARABIA TO DELAY
THE PRODUCTION DECREASE OF OIL
FOR A FEW MONTHS MEANING IT'S
LIKELY THAT MBS AND OPEC TOLD
JOE BIDEN RIGHT TO HIS FACE THAT
HE WOULD NOT ONLY PRODUCE MORE
OIL BUT HE CAN CUT PRODUCTION
AND HE WOULD CUT PRODUCTION
DRAMATICALLY.
"SAUDI OFFICIALS DID MISSED
BIDEN'S REQUEST AS THEY VIEWED
AS A POLITICAL GAMBET BY THE
ADMINISTRATION TO AVOID BAD NEWS
AHEAD OF THE U.S. MID-TERM
ELECTIONS."
THEY WERE RIGHT.
THEY LAUGHED IN HIS FACE.
THIS IS NOT JUST HUMILIATING FOR
JOE BIDEN, BUT HE WAS GRAVELLING
TO THE GUY THAT HE CALLED A
MURDERER.
THE MURDERER SPIT IN HIS FACE
AND SPIT IN THE FACE OF THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY.
THE USA.
DESPITE BIDEN'S EFFORTS TO KEEP
THIS QUIET, WE NOW KNOW THE
TRUTH AND JOE HAS NO LONG-TERM
SOLUTION FOR SPIKING GAS PRICES,
NO PLAN TO TAP INTO OUR OWN
DOMESTIC RESOURCES, NO NEW
PIPELINE DEALS ON DECK.
JUST A POLITICAL GAMBET AND IT
FAILED AND FAILED MISERABLY AND
WE'RE ALL PAYING THE PRICE FOR
IT.
NOW HE'S ACCUSING SAUDI ARABIA
AND OPEC FOR ALIGNING WITH
PUTIN, WHICH HAD ALREADY
HAPPENED.
HOW STUPID CAN JOE BE?
THEY WERE ALIGNING FOR QUITE
SOME TIME.
THEY HAD BEEN COORDINATING TO
DRIVE UP ENERGY COSTS BY
MANIPULATING THE WORLD'S SUPPLY
KNOWING THAT JOE BIDEN IS SO
STUPID AND SO BEHOLDEN TO THE
NEW GREEN DEAL SOCIALIST
DEMOCRATS THAT HE WILL
ARTIFICIALLY REDUCE THE WORLD
SUPPLY, WHICH MEANS THAT THEY
GET RICHER.
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO DENY JOE
BIDEN BEGGING AND PLEADING AGAIN
AND AGAIN.
JOE WILL KEEP BEGGING AND
HUMILIATING HIMSELF AND OUR
COUNTRY BECAUSE HE'S TOO STUPID
TO PRODUCE IT DOMESTICALLY AND
BECOME ENERGY INDEPENDENT LIKE
DONALD TRUMP DID.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR THE COUNTRY,
JOE BIDEN DOES NOT VALUE LOGIC
OR TRUTH.
HE BOWS AT THE DARK ALTER OF THE
CLIMATE ALARMIST RELIGIOUS CULT.
NEVER FORGET IT.
WITH EACH PASSING DAY, REALITY
BECOMES MORE AND MORE BLURRED
FOR THE PRESIDENT.
IN FACT, TODAY HE FALSELY CLAIMS
HIS SON, BEAU, LOST HIS LIFE IN
IRAQ.
THIS IS SCARY.
IT'S LIKE WHERE IS JACKIE
MOMENT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> JUST IMAGINE, I MEAN THIS
SINCERELY, I SAY THIS AS A
FATHER OF A MAN THAT WON THE
BRONZE STAR AND LOST HIS LIFE IN
IRAQ.
>> Sean: THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
HIS SON TRAGICALLY DIED FROM
CANCER SHORTLY AFTER HIS SECOND
TERM AS DELAWARE'S ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
TONIGHT IT IS NOT CLEAR IF BIDEN
IS CONFUSED, LYING OR BOTH.
I SUSPECT IT IS THE SIGNIFICANT
COGNITIVE DECLINE THAT WE
CHRONICLE REGULARLY.
EITHER WAY, IT'S NOT A GOOD LOOK
FROM THE GUY WHO HAS CHECKED HIS
WIFE OVER AND OVER AGAIN DURING
THE DIGNIFIED TRANSFER OF
SERVICE MEN AND WOMEN THAT WERE
KILLED IN AFGHANISTAN BECAUSE OF
JOE'S AWFUL AND DEADLY
WITHDRAWAL FROM KABUL.
FRANKLY BIDEN SEEMS PRETTY
CLASSLESS, SELF-ABSORBED ON CUE.
HERE'S JOE TALKING ABOUT HIMSELF
YET AGAIN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I GREW UP IN CLAYMOUNT,
DELAWARE.
I WENT TO A LITTLE SCHOOL CALLED
HOLY ROSARY ACROSS FROM THE FIRE
HALL.
ALL OF MY BUDDIES BECAME A
FIREFIGHTER, A COP OR A PRIEST.
I WASN'T QUALIFIED FOR ANY OF
THEM SO HERE I AM.
>> Sean: LAST PART IS TRUE.
YOU'RE NOT QUALIFIED TO BE
PRESIDENT.
GIVEN HIS FIRST TWO YEARS